(host)
Of all the many terrifying
fae-like monsters
haunting the waters
of the world,
the Nixie stands out.
These half-human
half-fish beings
may at first glance
look familiar,
but they are much
older and much scarier
than the usual mermaid
of pop culture.
Thanks, Ariel.
They love to shapeshift and
sing mesmerizing melodies
all while harboring
an insatiable desire for humans
which often veers
into a dark obsession.
So what is a Nixie?
A water sprite,
a nymph, a mermaid?
Technically, yeah.
[adventurous music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka
and this is "Monstrum."
The Nixie belongs
to a large Germanic tradition
of murderous
shapeshifting water nymphs
that also appear in folklore
from Switzerland
and Scandinavia.
Known throughout
folklore by many names,
these deadly and
enchanting water creatures
may take the appearance
of an old human
with green teeth,
green skin, and green hair.
Most of the time, though,
they take the form
of a beautiful human
covered with moss and seaweed
and decorated with shells.
Some German legends
describe the Nixie
with slit ears or fishtails
when they're in the water.
They have the ability to
appear clothed on land
but the water dripping
from their garments
gives away their true identity.
Throwing stones into the water
can irritate the Nixie
who may create
a storm in response.
Yep. These water monsters
control the weather.
An additionally scary thing
about the Nixie
is that they can haunt
any body of water.
No well, stream, river,
pond, lake or ocean is safe.
They lure their victims
with music, usually singing,
or in some stories they imitate
a crying child to
draw someone near
before seizing and pulling
their prey below the surface.
What they do with them
from there varies.
In many tales, the Nixie serve
as a cautionary
tale for children
who are told to avoid the water
so as not to be grabbed,
implying that
they will not return.
In other stories,
the monsters require
an annual human sacrifice
and they prefer children.
Stories of the deadly Nixie
usually end with death
but there are also accounts
of a more romantic persuasion.
Sometimes they will
transform into horses
to carry their
willing human lovers
to their crystal palaces.
Some of these monsters
apparently have alluring
underwater homes.
So yes, these stories implied
that the Nixie mate with humans.
Though such romantic encounters
are not encouraged
in their society,
said to be ruled by a malevolent
water diety akin to Satan.
Named Nick
from the ancient Icelandic,
he will kill any of the Nixie
who dare to even
talk to a human.
Described as more of
a classic mermaid or merman,
Old Nick is the fishtailed
father of all the Nixies.
Over time, and in some regions,
this water deity
became watered down
into the Nixies who
borrow his name.
Because of this
etymological connection,
the Nixie is
associated with malice
more often than many of
their global counterparts.
Before Nick,
and therefore all Nixies,
somewhere around 700 CE,
the famous text Beowulf
mentioned nickers,
violent water monsters.
Some folklore theorized that
Nixies may have originated
from ancient spiritual practices
of river and water god worship
that turned nefarious after the
introduction of Christianity
when water worship
was discouraged.
Still, whispers and legends
of the monster persisted
and became popular
across the globe
thanks to a few key books
in the 19th century.
In the German fairy tale
"Undine" published in 1811,
a Nixie, here
called water sprite,
appears on the doorstep
of a couple
whose daughter drowned
earlier that day.
Appearing as a young
human girl dripping wet,
she is taken in by
the grieving parents.
She's exquisitely
beautiful with golden hair,
but is also known to
have supernatural powers
like controlling
water and the weather,
and a fiery temperament.
Eventually,
Undine marries a knight,
and overnight becomes a nicer,
more accommodating person.
She claims the change is due
to her now possessing a soul.
Apparently, as a water
sprite she didn't have one
and can only get one
by marrying a human.
Even after she reveals
her true nature,
including her
people's great beauty
and otherworldly singing voices,
her husband seems okay
with the whole thing,
which granted doesn't seem
all that bad considering.
Her water sprite uncle, however,
is not pleased with this
intervening marriage
and repeatedly attacks the
couple and their company
with waves, frightening
apparitions, storms, and floods.
Eventually, Undine
is forced to return
to the Nixie's underwater
crystal kingdom
after her husband accuses
her of being a sorceress.
Meanwhile, her
former knight husband
remarries his former love
and the old couple's
biological daughter,
who in a strange twist,
didn't drown after all.
Due to the rules of
the Nixie society,
Undine must reappear on land
and give her husband a killer
kiss for his infidelity,
drowning him with her tears.
So we have a beautiful,
kind Nixie
who, yes, is forced
to kill her husband
but the tale is presented
as a tragic love story.
Oh, and this story,
yeah, it helped inspire
Han's Christian Anderson's
"The Little Mermaid."
The Nixie in the
Brothers Grimm 1857 tale,
"Nix of the Mill-Pond" lacks
any redeeming qualities.
A man who recently
lost his fortune
sees a beautiful woman
rise from the waters
of the river by his mill.
He recognizes her as
a Nixie straight off
and even though
he is frightened,
he accepts a strange
bargain from her.
She promises to
restore his wealth
if he pays her, "The young
thing which has just been born."
The young thing turns out
to be his firstborn son
whom his wife has
only just delivered.
When he realizes the
horror of what he has done,
he raises the boy
to fear the water.
This works until his son is
now a married man himself.
One day after a hunt,
without thinking,
the son washes his
hands in a pond.
The Nixie seizes
the opportunity.
She slowly rises
up from the water
and with a big smile,
wraps her arms around him,
dragging him down into
the water with her.
His distraught wife goes
to the local witch for help
who advises a series of
steps to bring him out.
First, she combs her hair near
the water where he was taken.
It works, sort of.
Her husband's head momentarily
appears above the surface
but quickly disappears
under the water again.
The next day, she plays a flute,
and this time half
of his body emerges.
On the third day,
she works a golden
spinning wheel by the pond
and her husband fully emerges.
He begins to leave the water
but not before a tidal wave
suddenly rises up
and starts heading towards them.
The woman calls upon the witch
with one last plea for help.
And help she does, by
turning the wife into a toad
and the huntsman into a frog,
enabling them to survive
the torrent of water.
Luckily, they revert back
to their human forms,
but unluckily, they are
separated by the wave.
They live separate
lives for years
until one day as fate would
have it, they cross paths.
They do not recognize
one another,
but become good friends.
One day, the Huntsman plays
an interesting flute song,
the very same one his wife did
besides the pond so
many years before.
They suddenly realize
who each other is
and fall back in love.
These stories
established the Nixie
as both villains and victims
and popularized the female
Nixie over the male Nix.
Nixies, along with other
water nymphs and mermaids,
appear often in
19th century fiction
as folkloric femme fatales
that reflect patriarchal
society's fear
of the
increasingly-liberated woman
and changing gender roles.
Because literature emphasizes
the beauty of the Nixie,
they're often seen as
projections of desire,
largely through the male gaze,
but others interpret
them as feminist symbols
of the power of women and
nature, as allegories for death,
or even as a reminder of
the dangers of drowning.
I think more broadly,
these 19th-century Nixies
gesture towards modernity,
their tempting songs
and offers of treasure
akin to the siren pull
of industrialization
which, likewise, promises
luxury and wealth
but at a severe cost.
According to folklore,
the Nixie lacks
maternal instinct,
sensibility, and a soul.
Having a fishtail,
supernatural foresight,
or the ability to shapeshift
are at odds with the parts of
them that are more human-like.
But it's the human side that
presents the most danger.
The mouth that can
tell the future
or lure one to a watery death.
Or the arms that pull
their prey down below.
It's the human qualities
that allow them to slip
into society unnoticed.
A wolf among sheep,
or rather,
a shark among seals.
Old Nick is the--
[whines] It went on my lip.
I'm sorry.
[crew laughs]
Okay. That time it landed on me.